repérez les fausses cartes resté discret
sur ce comment procèdent installait un
entrebâilleur des conseils pratiques de
la direction départementale de la
sécurité publique des yvelines une
soixantaine de personnes s'est déplacée
à la maison des familles de saint cyr
l'école mardi soir le but de
l'intervention faire des cibles
préférées des arnaqueurs des personnes
averties d'autant plus en cette période
de fin d'année et sa traditionnelle
vente de calendriers à domicile donc les
facteurs les pompiers en général on les
connaît puisant des calendriers
particulier qu'on reconnaît on se méfie
quand même parce qu'on sait jamais et
ensuite vous avez bas on a les éboueurs
on l'a entendu tout à l'heure des gens
qui se font passer par des pour des
associations caritatives et qui veulent
vendre des calendriers et là la ligne de
conduite dire ok je veux donner aux
éboueurs donc je donne au moment où ils
ramassent les poubelles et si je veux
donner une association caritative bajeux
fera un don soit en ligne sur internet
je ferai un donjon vers un chèque à
l'association
le dernière révision pour les seniors
qui ont pris note de tous ces conseils
on nous a montré des cartes
professionnelles de police qui sont
nouvelles
ils sont pas du tout celles de julie
lescaut ou de corinne touzet plus d'
arnaque possible à saint-cyr-l'ecole
maintenant que la population est averti
et si jamais vous avez des doutes
la police rappelle de ne pas hésiter à
faire le 17